doing it like that that's not how he
sounds that doesn't mean that's exactly
how he says
he was like
yeah but i don't need to do this
no well yeah but but still oh my god you
can see your mouth through it
right and it lights up
i'm a villain this is awesome it's
actually a very creepy mouthful
it is creepy it looks like you're at the
dentist it looks like you're like
getting a scan you got a couple of
cavities back here we're going to fill
in but don't worry about it that's going
to give you some nitrous and you the
fact that where's your duchess
from now here's the deal like i've got
some flights coming up and there has not
been so far a single mask
even the ones are like this is the most
comfortable mask you can possibly they
all
right back here they do oh my god the
the 16-hour australia flight my the back
of my ears was killing me i i've tried
these this is what i use because i have
a big [ __ ] skull they go all the way
around so they don't get your ears no
link me link me
this thing
until i until i get rid of this which um
maybe soon i don't know
this is a thing from asks too
i would just like to say welcome back i
would love to see you on the flight
easily welcome back to play watch listen
audio listeners troy has one of those
razer
masks how else do you describe it
i can't show you the box they said don't
show the box i was like okay but it's
called project
oh shoot it's very charming that two
weeks off and it's it's like we'd never
it's like we've been continuously
recording this entire time not only that
but also like the travels and
actually sorry about that
let's show you the box
so project zephyr is what it's called
um and they reached out they were like
hey can we send you one i was like yeah
yes that's a really interesting name for
a product
i don't understand why you wouldn't want
to show the box by the way not sponsored
at all this is not there's nothing they
they you say on your razor chair
oh yeah dude with your razor moss these
p these piece be hooking me up for real
sponsored but they were just literally a
tattoo recently added yeah
so whatever and i misspelled it too and
they're like damn it there is an e i was
like oh i thought it was like the phone
can you can you bring it back though
troy i would
like to
see it
yeah what other functionality
so the question the reason why you were
hearing the fans or the the
where's is they have these magnetic
things that and you put filters in there
and so you can change out the filters so
it's actually filtering in
and it brings in fresh air because the
thing that i hate about mass is that you
just feel like [ __ ]
it's like
working out
like if i i'm now building a gym in the
house but like i i took this to the gym
and everyone's like
that thing you're right dude i gave two
shits cause they're like you gotta wear
a gym in the mask you gotta work you
gotta wear the mask you gotta wear the
gym
remember guys troy says you got to wear
a gym in the mask if you were if you
take one thing away from this episode
i used to i used to say i have uh i have
blonde hair and blue eyes and i know i
would say buy a blue hair and blonde
eyes people were like cool what reese
are you is like i'm a half fling um
but that's not accurate but no i wore
this at the gym and people were like
that's stupid and then they saw it it
wasn't like
where'd you get that like you can't get
it i'm more important than you
why is mike frozen he's not
for me he is but he's also in a new a
new place you haven't you set up mike
look at that with the lighting room
he's got a room of my very own i feel is
that the same bookshelf
interestingly this is a different
bookshelf that was just out of shot in
the last ones this is such a present
just such a such a wanker it's the
current this is a traditional shelf are
you facing the books
no can you will you be able because that
would be the ultimate win if you could
just like reach above camera yeah
exactly
we didn't have we didn't have enough
unfortunately all of our but we just now
got our downstairs we just got like a
wall of bookshelves which is awesome it
doesn't mean if you if your books are
not part of the show i feel like we
might have to recast
troy
that's our first crotch shot
it's amazing
i think it was actually the box uh
the magnetic pull of the box for the
mask i am [ __ ] i am so glad you guys
don't understand it's a goddamn coin
flip every time we do this whether or
not i'm gonna wear pants
i i hear you i've definitely recorded
episodes of this show without pants we
could have made a lot of money
and now i'm sort of disappointed that we
didn't get
that which i would not have edited out
play watch listen only fans
who are very concerned that the bookcase
was no longer going to be there i just
assumed that this bookcase that's behind
you is still full
of things that are entirely relevant to
this show i i have a feeling that we
will find uses for the bookshelf it's uh
i have a selection this is mainly stuff
like i'm reading it's a big reach though
i feel like you gotta you gotta really
go on a distribute smaller than looks
oh you're right
it looks about the size yeah
no dude that's weird
i don't like it i don't like changing i
like it i'm sorry
change your house move austin your setup
is pretty much the same except now you
have a cap on the top of your piano
that's exciting oh cause i got a haircut
you got it you did get a haircut look at
this changing i know
i hate it i don't like this what a
journey we've been on yeah
how's everybody lana i love your
background today that's okay thank you i
know this is also weirdly the first
episode where i was like i don't have
time to choose a background for the
green screen so it's just green but it's
different to the various wait a minute
oh [ __ ] so can you not change that after
the fact i could but everybody would see
it because i screen capture so they
would see me not that that matters
they're just like don't want to have
them have to look on my uh magic does
that mean you remember when the queen
did the whole thing she like she did the
the address in
a green
blouse top whatever it was and people
just were like we're going crazy
are people going to do that now with you
they could they could always suggest
that yeah yeah yeah can you
no no because they can't do it
i'm officially offering a bounty for the
best one oh my god please
what's the value
we could do it in post like we could ask
the editor to do something no no no no
no
austin will play a tune of your choice
on the next episode
if you win the competition yourself
please send all entries to austin not
the rest of us
pure evil i would also love for people
to just like do bad lip reading of us
what if people made more content that's
about me you know what
isn't that the thing though like
youtubers are doing react videos to
their own videos
no you just watched bo burnham special
and got confused i think i actually i i
i'm pretty excited about it really good
by the way yeah i do really want to
watch it i made a time capsule on
youtube
four years ago that's four or five years
in the future so next year i get to
watch it it's private so nobody can see
it but uh i basically like i think it's
maybe 10 minutes long and i just talk
about where i'm at in life and what i'm
doing and what i intend to be doing and
i'm really excited to watch it back
that would that would both terrify
because the whole thing about the you
saw the mean those but not meme there
was a challenge i don't recall the
twitter is like hey post a 90s picture
of yourself with no context or or
caption
and boy man night the 90s were uh
that was not five years ago when i
recorded this time capsule uh is the
good news
no but like in the 90s
i know what you mean though it's i don't
want to think about the 90s i don't want
to look back at the images of myself
i th this last week i went back through
and i played like i was like i i finally
i've been trying to be diligent and
right now it's kind of a chill time as
someone said i'm falling apart in
between jobs
um
and so as i'm as i'm between jobs
um
the
i've really tried to make time to to
play games like i've sat down and and
just
from a pure entertainment standpoint
just played games
like i and i've really wanted to and
i've gone back here to this machine the
[ __ ] it is that over there and like
cranked up some old games is that zak
son that's playing right now i don't
know if you guys remember zaxxon at all
but i played the [ __ ] out of that in the
arcade had the really cool joystick um
and then i went and played
brothers in arms um hell's highway
dude that game's still that's at 10
years old and that game still hold over
10 years um 15 years old um that game
still holds up
the mechanics of it are still great
um it's always fun shooting nazis
it's true yeah i love that it's timeless
insane um
but i did go back through and there was
there were some games that like when the
first iphone came out
and like we saw with i had a question if
if we can talk about that like pt right
is is a great example of this to where
alana you have a a ps3 i think it is
that you will never plug back into the
internet for fear of
taking that from the ps4 yeah i will
never get rid of it no i love so much i
had to pull down my my 360 because i was
like i really want to play modern
warfare 2
i want to play the spec ops missions and
they didn't they made it i found out
they made it
backwards compatible on xbox one and so
i was able to do that and dude that
thing is just it's at whatever you can i
i still think call of duty is great it's
gotten weird and mine included but it is
just
that specifically was just such a it's
it's a great speaking of a time capsule
i i remember where i was in life what i
was doing who i was with and there's so
many things that i associate with those
sights and sounds
but i was afraid that i was never going
to be able to play that again because
the remastered version that they put out
they specifically took away the
multiplayer and the spec ops
because it's a huge thing we've talked
about reboots and remasters and
everything
but do you think now
games if if
they're no longer on a viable platform
like they stopped making ps3 stuff and
like you have to keep your original
machine or you have to have one of these
guys like if there's no emulators if
there's no
or right now what we're seeing is like
if devs can't continue to support by
having their servers online or they lose
their deal with the publisher let's
let's say it's like game pass or or
steam or whatever
can games go extinct
yes
dude
yes there is
that one game that was that was the
whole point of it but it was just like
are we seeing a whole new wave of games
where it's like this game could
potentially be there's a game called
glider that i'll do my iphone i can't
play it anymore and i wish i could
that's a whole subject i mean the whole
idea of how do you preserve in a
historical
kind of way this
art form which is ironically given how
storied how storable digital media is
compared to physical media it is an
oddly ephemeral
art form uh given how
technology ages out
um and i remember when chris melacinos
and that whole uh like smithsonian
touring show
of the art of video games uh there was
that whole discussion around that of how
do you
preserve in the museum sense old games
uh it's actually quite hard you know
like if you have an
atari game that you know
obviously like you said emulators are
what not notwithstanding you know some
these these machines eventually break
down yeah right um you know they just
don't work anymore there is an
organization uh who i've worked with
before i think it's just video game
conservationist society i think is what
they're called i may have gotten that
wrong but i can leave a link in the
description who specifically works on
trying to maintain video games which we
can lose and frequently do lose like
it's very very easy to lose a video game
there are games that i've seen spoken
about in documentaries that out of
curiosity i've tried to track down games
i've never heard of that were pivotal in
something um that you just can't even
find anymore and i don't know if it's
just me but i get this like tremendous
sense of anxiety thinking about it like
the loss of
video game history like freaks me out i
don't know why
but there are people who i i it's an
organization charitable organization you
can donate to who are trying to maintain
video game history and hardware and all
that stuff i mean there's it's still a
valid business that people oh my
my bounty for the best green screen will
be a donation and that person's name to
the video game preservation organization
let me look up actually i'll match the
[ __ ] company yes god give it yes
they're gonna be sitting there and
they're like why did we just get like
thousands of dollars out of nowhere hold
on
you're spending three people's money
right now exactly that's the thing
you're trying to fast and lose
we should probably leave
it's
far more fun when it's other people's
money so yeah
do you take that into account like or
can you even think that long like are
you trying to make a game that has that
kind of longevity or do you go
i'm just trying to make a game that has
a shelf life of x amount of years and if
so how long is that
it's really tough because i mean it's
it's it's there's so many layers because
it's not even just the um
it's not even well so it's the hardware
obviously the hardware is specific and
bespoke and degrades it's the software
so it's what like with your phone games
troy literally like the the phone os is
just block and kill old games regularly
there's i think actually thomas was
alone you can't go on mobile phones
anymore i think that's been
surpassed by the by the platform um so
that's already happened in our you know
since thomas was alone which is
nearly it's heading towards 10 years old
now and that's you know that's already
dead on mobile um unless we you know do
a port basically do a new port um
there's those then there's also like
licensing deals like if you're like try
and find a copy of like the deadpool
video game that came on xbox 360 you
won't be able to really right um
do you find it physically but it's not
going to be on any of the storefronts
because those licenses are time limited
so you can't
that was activision
it would have been activision doing a
deal with marvel and then but but every
there's no such thing as like a
licensing deal in perpetuity like
western
west i hate
there's i know there are people i mean
i've i've done a license game recently
and and like i i stay in touch with
people it's it is
there are people who are trying to work
out a pro solution to that problem but
that like legally these games disappear
very quickly like you know licensed
games for that reason not dissimilar to
streaming services i suppose that's why
they keep jumping across platforms
exactly yeah look at streaming services
look how many things have got lost in
the mix where you where you end up with
something where it's on a streaming
platform so they stopped printing the
dvd and then it goes off the stream
platform and like yeah things disappear
what i would say is we're not if you
think about this in a bigger context
we're no different to any of the
people's before us like if you you try
and find a copy of a specific book from
like the victorian era or a specific
kind of there are or or even just if you
think about the history of cinema like
the the the actual number of surviving
movies
versus oh my god number of movies that
were made it's nothing right and even
for the big names like there are massive
the equivalent of what we would now call
a blockbuster movies where we just have
like two publicity stills and that's the
entire history of that there are there
are these kind of these these kind of
moby dicks of the film world basically
that are like these
everyone's looking for these film kinds
just because there are these massive
movies that just disappeared two great
examples of that
library
i remember walking out of my apartment i
lived in north hollywood and that's just
you know a stone's throw three four
miles away from universal city which is
where the um and then there's also the
warner brothers a lot too which is why
television is made basically yeah so
that's that's studio city which is you
know cbs paramount and the radford stage
and there's also universal city and then
there's also the warner brothers lot are
all just all in burbank
uh burbank and studio city so i'm kind
of at the the
the
point where those two converge
i remember walking out
on my out of my apartment and on my
stoop i looked and i was like oh smoke
that's really really close and that was
the warner brothers fire and a dear
friend of mine gary mariano who's the
publicist for warner brothers he's like
you have no idea the amount of ego
celluloid is incredibly flammable
and that vault what's the cell fire
yeah film oh film cells oh oh sure
he's like wow and so he was like there
are original prints of stuff that just
were lost they're gone but it also
degrades just naturally like they it
turns out but they put them in these
airtight vaults exactly keep them from
doing just that but somehow it caught
and it just like because that that was
that was gone
um it feels like we should be willing to
let things go realistically we should be
okay with it but i'm not well you could
argue that's the entire human condition
yeah but we are always searching for the
new thing right and that's why it's why
agent smith describes this as a disease
it's a
it's the disease
it's the smell but like it's it is like
constantly
that constant search for the new and
that society is always pushing forward
it's probably a good thing the reality
is the reason we don't have all of these
movies is because no one wanted to watch
them like it's it's it's it does fade i
do think with video games in particular
well hey i care a lot about video games
because i work in them but the i think
we are it's i do i've
but we are in this really exciting
moment i think as well with games what's
fascinating
um to me at least is is the is also the
supporting materials is also just the
kind of the the production of video
games we're terrible at documenting yeah
the number of like post-it notes and
documents and things that just disappear
i know i know like
you know
famous game developers who basically are
now trying to like find all of their old
stuff because they they accidentally
made a hit a massive important video
game jordan
anything like that that whole story it
is it is such a fascinating story that
he
his dad i'm probably misquoting him um
but his dad while cleaning out his attic
found
um
the original code for prince of persia
it's just a box discarded box
and there's a there was an article that
i think is either esquire gq again i
apologize for not being able to
accurately quote the source but they he
said i i watched as we had to bring over
an apple ii
and get that thing to work and then put
in the original programming he was like
i watched this thing come to life i was
like we came a hair's breath away
from losing that original code and i i
feel like there's such a huge story to
be told there about all of the games
that
went extinct
like there's there's games that of
course it's like you said it's great to
have on the emulator but speaking to the
licensing thing wes keltner
um
good dude uh at wes keltner on on
twitter was talking about um how can
licensed content be removed from a game
and he does this you know five little
minute video talking about that he was
like
people are like i can't believe they
took that out i'm like there's a reason
why and it's either their deal came up
and they couldn't renew it
or
they asked for something that they
you know weren't going to get and they
just yanked the license content
and that could get worse that could get
much much worse because now a bunch of
indie games
my own included and a lot of aaa as well
are being made with a bunch of licensed
technology so there's actual code in
these games that is not owned by the
people who make those games so
theoretically like uh for example
use triple a as example right okay so
wise w right is like the de facto or
audio engine toolkit used for everything
like troy your voice has been played
through wise a billion times in a
billion triple a games um i think that's
how many you're in right a billion
triple a games just out of this video
you're working on yourself
i'll get there next year
but like imagine if
that license was revoked or that company
went defunct in a way that meant that
those games couldn't be port upgrade
doesn't mean that you know there's lots
of clever people in the games industry
i'm sure we work workarounds but would
we bother with every game no and that's
you know there's there's a lot of if you
think i collect vinyl and what's great
about vinyl is this time capsule there's
if i can if i can grab a record from any
point in history where we've made
records i could put in a modern record
player and it will play yeah there's no
middleware there's no whatever we put
that on the voyager that's why we
printed that thing on gold exactly
and it's like
and that's fascinating and cool but
that's not the medium we work in we work
in something we work in a a little
beautiful artistic
we're the the gold spike on the top of
the pyramid right and if anything
crumbles below it
we're we're our spike falls that thing
was also stolen
when you're working on something you
generally aren't thinking about how it's
going to be
preserved you just aren't thinking about
that um with the exception of uh
ethan and markiplier gameplays in
markiplier i don't know if you would
have seen this mic
two um big youtube creators and ethan's
one of my best friends who made a
youtube channel that intentionally they
wanted everything to disappear after a
year
so videos would go up every day and then
at the end of the year the whole channel
was deleted um and i think they're still
dealing with people you know obviously
having saved a lot of it and trying to
re-upload it and they're going through
the process of like making sure that
they delete all of that but it was a
really interesting experiment to watch
two people go through the idea of
working their asses off on something and
then erasing absolutely all of it and
how they felt afterwards and it actually
seemed like it was kind of relieving
like it seemed like the letting go of
something was a lot of relief but then
i've also you know worked at funhouse
where
all of inside gaming and a lot of their
videos which are originally on the
machinima youtube channel which got
completely deleted so a lot of their
work is just completely gone um the tv
show that i worked on
in australia there are some clips on
youtube a lot of little breakouts but no
full episodes of the entire show exist
anywhere and it's not something that
that bothers me but it is a question
it's like is it worth trying to preserve
that stuff when you're in the act of
creating something because i do think
that the preservation of processes can
really help other people learn you know
oh i just got a gift from zoom
this meeting has been upgraded by the
host and now it includes unlimited
minutes wow thank you
[Laughter]
um but i don't know like what what's the
approach because i i do it for myself
whenever i'm writing fiction i keep
everything i keep all of my non-stocks
but i just do that for myself i don't
keep youtube videos i delete all of them
i know some youtubers who make sure that
they keep all of them and have folders
and terabytes full of that stuff but i
erase everything the minute that it's up
and it's just a question of like is it
worth it like do we think that there is
value in keeping
the unedited processes of things so that
we can help other people
i
i
i equate a lot of stuff and life to
music because that was just my original
path and so for me there's a lot of
analogs that still apply
and one of my favorite things um
i don't have this anymore and i wish i
did there was a book
of someone that comprised all of the
gear that the beatles used in studio
and so you're do you have dude there's
no way
if you
i was just taking a bit now i don't i
don't have it i don't have it
i'm looking i have you on two screens as
i'm looking over here and i saw you do
that i'm like
if you pulled that book out i would be
like no i was like you're not human you
have
now what i i was looking for was i have
the most boring version of this which i
have a book on the history of forms like
literally like documentation
of like it's it's just the most boring
version of this idea of like archives
i'm very interested in whatever that is
dude it's fascinating like as someone
who's like deals with like
uh
like like asking like player interaction
feedback tutorials like looking at like
how forms are structured is very useful
to me anyway troy you're an intro middle
of an interesting strategy
i have a i have a um a really cheap poor
man's version of of uh leonardo because
obviously they're like at some museum i
think they're they feed see but the
leonardo dicap
yeah leonardo da vinci
the other one basically the same thing
the other one there's three leonardo's
that everybody knows one's a turtle
one's an artist and one's an actor um
the
his his journals his diaries were um
obviously one of the most famous where
we get the the
anyway they're great but so many of them
i i loved because of the the quotes that
he had and um
those
seeing the the inner musings of someone
who is is regarded
as being one of the most creative minds
inventive minds
um that's something that is of interest
to me because i want to see how my
processes compare contrast or clash with
that i want to see it's like am i
thinking about problems in a in a way
that this person did the same thing but
his always yielded a result
um
and so like that looking at the beatles
i i remember when i did my first album
our engineer had a binder that was just
full of notes of like
this channel routes to this and this is
the plug-in this is the signal changes
like if i ever have to pull this back up
i don't know how it did that and i can't
just all from memory and so someone did
that for for the beatles um and it was
fascinating to see like that's how they
got that sound as they just like yeah
man we actually just we put this through
here and
a day in the life is a great example
they they went through all three rooms
of abbey road because they needed more
tracks and they had four tracks that's
every studio had a four-track recorder
so you could only do four trikes
simultaneously at a time and they needed
way more so they went through and there
was no way to connect those things so
paul
literally ran through and went press
play and record playing record play and
record on each of those four tracks so
they could have 12 tracks simultaneously
and it's just it's it's hearing stories
about and now you look at that and i
have on pro tools i have unlimited
tracks i can record 99 things at a time
it's stupid
so being able to look at that to me is
of
of great interest because i want to i'm
fascinated by the process and to me the
process is the point it's it's once the
thing is made once the product is out
i can't do anything with that
i can't change it i can't really even
learn from it i can only learn from the
process so books about the process
interest me greatly troy most of what
you've worked on
you wouldn't have access to any of the
process right like in terms of voice
acting for a triple-a game
that belongs to them do you have any say
in what they do with any
of no and and i learned a very valuable
lesson from a great director who said
and this is the
top of the top of the list
um
and he said
my job is to do this i don't have to
worry about the cover box i have to
worry about even the editing i don't he
goes i my job is to let it go
and he goes then it's somebody else's
job and i'm like have you ever just
disagreed was like oh my god
fundamentally i've slept under my bed
i'm crying so hard
but that's not the point my point is i
did my job i got to walk away
and that's a that was a very valuable
lesson to me because i'm always trying
to it's like i asked you mike i was like
are you thinking about the long term are
you thinking about the shelf life of
this are you thinking about how you can
preserve this and i i see in my own
specifically in as an actor if i'm
focusing on what the metacritic is or
how people are going to view this scene
or if they're going to believe me as
this character i am 100
telling the character to get the [ __ ]
out of the scene because all my ego is
filling up this room
so i really have to focus on does it
matter
doesn't matter and honestly you can't
take it out personally right you have to
move on you have to i think definitely
when i was younger
i equated you know the things i make
with myself like the things i make
defined me they were like you know
if i made something bad then that then i
sucked and it was or if i made something
excellent then i was a genius it's kind
of like there's i think one of the
things you learn as you go through the
process of the loop a few times is
you're still you and the product that
you're making is not defining you and
your relationships with people and who
you are as a person
and you do kind of learn or i've learned
to yeah i i will care
more about a game
than anything for the time of making it
but once you release it yeah you walk
away because otherwise you'll go
absolutely crazy and also you can't
change or fix anything obviously
nowadays you can update and tweak and of
course you do do that but like
on an on a more you know an emotional
level you can't fundamentally change
something you can't you can't put the
genie back in a bottle so therefore um
not beating yourself up not making it
about
like you say not tying it to your ego
not making it for better or worse about
you i think is is a is a good healthy i
was talking to someone someone someone
said very similar on twitter a couple
days ago and it was you know it was
really it's definitely a i think it's a
fro a moment that every creative goes
through at some point where they realize
no i i'm more than what i make
um and also less and that's okay and
it's kind of it's nice to be separating
yourself from yourself i i think it's
just you got to make it i in the same
way that i i
i'm not going to obsess over
i'm not even going to go down i was
going to do a terrible analogy i'm just
not going to do it okay he's going to
bring up hitler it was the whole thing
to bring an answer to your questions
totally a struggle
i was going to say a lot of to answer
your question what i've done now is i've
asked
not demanded i've asked can i be a part
of the process so that i can understand
better if
first of all i want to ask what it where
is my seat and at what table am i sat at
and if they go we really want you to be
an ad hoc partner there's there's some
projects that i'm working on right now
where they're like no we want you to be
involved not just in the
um the building of this character so
that you can fully own it which is not
really true because it's not just me
there's animators there's coders there's
there's
dozens on this to this team there's
dozens of people that would touch that
because it's a smaller team but there's
also hundreds or thousands if it's a
triple-a so it's i don't own anything i
am part of it and i do my job and i move
on
but if somebody says we want you to be
an ad-hoc member of this team and if we
were to give out a dev team t-shirt
i don't want that to be just something
cute that they did
i want that to be like no you [ __ ]
earned this like you're part of the dev
team which means you go down with us too
if this thing bombs
then you go down and i i've really
applauded and and um
not revered but i've admired people who
who've stood by their team in their
studio
um
when they the game has gotten tanked or
you know when when they because i've
been a part of that too where it's like
the shadow of war was a perfect example
of that great game that
they
they added one thing in there that just
overshadowed everything about it it
became the story right it became the
story so people are like oh no it's not
even cool to light the game and the the
most anticipated game
of that of that year ended up becoming
the most
it was a pariah no one would play the
game and it's a beautiful game we worked
our asses off for that and i really
admired everyone that stood by it and
was like we made a great game and just
took the [ __ ] the onslaught of [ __ ] that
they got
from from top down anyway but i have
asked if i can be a part of that process
and if people bring me in i want to know
and so now being brought into those
meetings where it's like
we're this is what we're
talking about we're trying to figure out
what zero what has to be a zero one has
to be a one in this code for this
thing this walk cycle to work that's
what we're talking about today i'm like
holy [ __ ]
and
it is fascinating to me
thomas was alone
looking at it from just like a pure
design
an implementation and execution
standpoint i'm like it's magic it's it's
nothing short of magic i don't
understand how you did it um the art of
game design is a beautiful book if i
could reach it i would what do you got
right there
the magic book
i really expected it to be something to
do with thomas was alone because that
would make so much sense but yeah if
you're like
instead you pull out the magic book yeah
it's the thing that excites me the most
about being uh
back in the studio more at sms is like i
just want to learn what everybody does
so bad i want to be able to walk up to
somebody's desk and be like how this
happened
it's just so much more access to people
that really excited
yeah and it's the best part being a
director as well because you basically
get to interact with absolutely everyone
and
bounce off of everyone and it's just
people who are absolute experts in what
they do who know more than i will ever
know and that i get to be in a building
with a bunch of them and be like holy
[ __ ] you're at the top of your game for
this thing that i will never understand
and i can i can speak to you about it
like it just feels like such a
tremendous privilege
to be able to have access to those kinds
of people but this entire conversation
we're having is actually sort of
relevant to
something that's happening to an indie
team right now we're doing a topic
mike i imagine you've seen it have you
seen the the boyfriend dungeon
conversation boyfriend thing yeah i
haven't what is it i'll i'll play the
part of the audience i have
unfortunately not played the game uh and
i almost boyfriend dungeon is the game
correct and i also don't use twitter
very much these days so i always feel
like i'm missing takes um but
essentially uh indie game uh that is
sort of a dating sim i feel like it's
it's a bit more um
involved than that but uh yeah it's a
bit more of a yeah it's got it's got a
kind of a combat mechanic yeah as well
yeah um and it has a content warning at
the start where you can disable um
messages from your mother in the game i
believe
uh but
try to skirt around spoilers as well
with also trying to maintain any
accuracy here a i recommend everybody
read up on this then use me for a source
clearly um but essentially there is a
character slash theme that a lot of
people have found to be very distressing
and there has been
this
very
potent conversation about whether there
should have been a content warning for
that theme
uh and also
a lot of people asking for there to be
an option to disable it
so there was a content warning for the
theme is my understanding
i don't think it was in any trailers or
on like the store page or anywhere where
you can buy the game sorry yeah in-game
i think there is a content warning that
again try to avoid spoilers that says
that that content is in there yeah um
but yes i think people cr it's it's
fascinating it's very interesting that's
because the conversation is how that
ties to what we were just talking about
it's very much the conversation about
that game um while also tying into our
conversation here about preserving
something and that people are asking for
the content to be removed and there's
been all of these really interesting
just from what i've seen discussions of
consent where people are like i didn't
consent to this experience and how that
applies to a video game
where
you know should should there be content
warnings should there be an option to
remove these kind of things i feel like
i want to stand by
no i think that we should be supporting
the cindy studio and telling the story
they want to tell with the themes that
are very difficult i do think they
probably could have been clearer about
the content warning
however i also think it's very difficult
to give content warnings because people
can be triggered by so many things
because we have so many unique
experiences
so it i think it mostly really sucks
with the cindy studio that they have
become a conversation
rather than which is what every indicio
wants to avoid is becoming of the
discourse yeah and it's also
i just feel like we're so
critical
the conversation that comes around
games like this um often coming from
like lgbt teams
and the themes that they tackle from an
indie studio i just feel like the
criticism they like i don't see anything
from more mainstream games having oh but
you didn't i didn't get consent for no
russian you didn't ask for consent i
just feel like it's everyone's being so
critical of them perfect example though
i can't think of a
an example
of a game going and matter of fact that
was after the fact
the no russian
that that was a patch
they shipped the game
we were at the launch party in vegas and
then the russia news hit and they were
like everybody like
dispersed because they were like we got
a fire to put out
because people are pissed
and so they put in the
i just played it again it was like turn
on the graphic uh turn off you know
graphic content do you consent to this
yes are you sure you can turn this off
at any other time don't ask me again
x done
i
i i that right there in the same way
that i feel that o.j simpson is one of
the most seminal pivotal important
people in modern history
because
all of a sudden he became the archetype
for we will watch bad [ __ ] happen live
on tv and he became the progenitor for
24-hour news channel
and the second that it started to die
off boom then we had 911 and that went
really well but people before would
watch
the birth of the procedural happened
because of
o.j simpson the kardashians which cree
spawned all of this social media culture
came out of o.j simpson
that whole thing that 94 was just one of
the most pivotal seminal years for
modern history modern human history
i can't think of any time i played
anything before
metal gear solid which had you know
rampant violence
nobody really ever said do you consent
to this and it was
i mean defensively it was one of the
most disturbing scenes that happened in
a video game people were like holy [ __ ]
when i remember when we made it um that
was my character i played joseph allen
they're like here's the scene you're
walking through an airport i'm like holy
[ __ ]
are like are you co they asked me like
are you cool with this i'm like yeah i
think what a what a truly visceral
experience this is modern warfare is
here to show the horrors of war you're
right it's also a bold comment i think
that's why i appreciate no russian like
one of my least favorite parts of any
video game that i've ever played that is
also a game that i love
is in gta 5 as trevor you have to
torture someone and i so badly wish that
i could have swapped to michael and
listen to it on the phone so i could
still understand why it's there but you
have to do it and you have to do it for
a long time or at least it felt that way
i [ __ ] hated it like when that was
happening yes i would have opted to do
anything else like don't make me do this
let me hit a button and not do this i'm
so uncomfortable with the content while
also understanding why it's there and
what it says about trevor as a character
and respecting why it exists in the game
but you don't have to that's the whole
thing you don't have to watch this
it's true
it is true it's not but it's but that's
you know and that's what's interesting
about games is they you're right troy
but at the same time like at the point
where alana got to that moment she'd
invested a long time it's pretty late in
the game yeah a long time it's late in
the game but no yeah i didn't get mad at
anyone is what i'll say i didn't go on
twitter i didn't get mad at anyone i
just [ __ ] hated it or until the
creators you need to change something or
fire someone none of that none of that
so what's interesting though it's as
fascinating to me because i think it's a
generational thing as well i think there
is i think there's a generation coming
up and i'm not i don't think this isn't
necessarily a bad thing but i i think
it's probably a good thing is i think
they are i think basically the audience
becoming much more comfortable with
telling us what they want but better or
worse and they can more easily and they
can more easily um
i also i also think that it is it's it's
a it's an interesting i'm i'm this is
intriguing to me as someone who tells
stories because one of i think the
aspect that a lot of writers are freaked
out by with this is essentially there is
a character in the game
who's a villain who is cast as a villain
who's explained to me a villain
who in enacts this bad behavior right
this is a classic character turn where
someone
is a good person and then you realize oh
that's you they're evil and they're
they're the bad guy right
that's what we're talking about here and
the manner in which they're bad
it's triggering which that's why there's
a content warning i'm sure
but i'd also understand the argument for
it needing to be elsewhere as well
but
if we can't make villains that are bad
people and talk about bad people and and
create content which explores badness as
a concept and stuff and even from like
uh even if you're going purely from like
an educational point of view
i learned about i mean star trek taught
me morals as a kid right like there's a
there's a
and that was because i was watching on
like at 6 p.m on the british tv
kardashians torturing bajorans right and
like learning like okay that's
that's obviously bad but also where's
the interesting kind of nuance of deep
space nine and all this stuff like if we
can't approach these subjects if we
can't talk about if we have to make
wholesome content which is another thing
that intersects especially with what you
were saying alana of um lgbtq creators
are often expected to make wholesome
games to make games that um
show the good side or or the only the
positivity of the of the romance and of
the of the culture they're representing
they that's that's really
limiting to artists and there are lgbtq
creators who want to talk about scary
stuff bad stuff stuff that you know
negative experiences they've had and to
go to that or to those creators and say
no you can't do this is is really kind
of limiting and scary too when they're
already so limited you know stories
that's the thing exactly and
it's also coming from inside the house
to extend this isn't this isn't the
usual like stack of awful bigots who who
said trash this is this is people who
are you know on the progressive side of
the fence who often who are kind of like
trying to limit this this creative
outlet and it's interesting i the
consent thing confuses me because it
feels like consent has a very real
meaning in the real world and
conflating that with the fiction you're
being entertained by i don't i don't
understand that at all i think like
i admit to being ignorant on this topic
i have not read into it enough i am
ignorant done um i think maybe it's
developed with this generation beyond
what it means for our generation perhaps
maybe but i i generally where the
consent thing is concerned and i again i
really should look into this to try to
get more perspectives but i feel like
right my gut reaction to seeing some of
that commentary was the same as what
troy just did which is isn't your
consent
you putting the controller down like if
you don't want it you you cannot play it
but then i also understand you know
people being invested and and i feel
like it's probably more complicated than
that but that is my immediate reaction
is is isn't consent in a video game
choosing to play it
yeah especially when there's a there's a
financial investment like
most people do not have they'll be able
to buy maybe four games game pass for
them for the consumer is a fantastic
option because it now
opens up the ability to be able to play
a lot more i'm
i remember when
i used to sell um mobile phones
and this was in the
late 90s and i remember we may have even
talked about this on the show i remember
the first time um my manager on a
saturday opened up in in the newspaper
it's like everything that i'm saying
right now is just the most like
anachronic my manager on a saturday i
was reading about paper newspaper it was
a newspaper he said by bringing the
newspaper that'll be nickel sir
uh run on down to the candy store get
yourself a lolly um
he opens it up and he looked he was like
holy [ __ ]
i was like what he was like i think
you'll find he was like oh golly i can't
believe this is actually happening look
at that eyes are now reelected
he said he was like the game just
changed
i went what
the motorola star attack was one of the
most ubiquitous
and um it was the elite phone like it
was the small flip clam shell phone it
was in every movie everybody wanted it
was like that was the status symbol
and it was the most expensive phone it
was like
600 bucks 500 bucks or whatever and
there was a there was a competitive
store that had advertised big one page
thing
get the star attack for one
penny
essentially for free
and he was like i know what they're
doing they're taking the loss because
they get paid by the person when you
sign up for a contract so they're just
taking less money but what ended up
happening is overnight people looked at
a phone
and said this is worthless it's worth a
penny i paid a penny for this phone well
yeah if you buy another one you have to
pay 600 bucks like no it wasn't until
the iphone
that people were like oh [ __ ] phones are
you have attacked money i think you have
a text message i do you have a text
which just show you on the screen if
it's something you want to blur out jack
i was a jack oh it's jack don't worry
about it that's fine
yeah you can you're speaking
i think the thing that we often miss
with exactly the thing you're describing
there
is that our relationship to products and
to entertainment is changing into a more
long-term relationship and more of an
invested i agree a personal level
relationship we're not when you're
playing a game yes you've spent some
money yes you spent some time
but you're also in that world you're
engaged with that in a long-term way
and and it means more i think that i
think it's it's one thing and you see
this throughout the throughout
throughout entertainment but it's why
it's when we say put down the controller
but at the same time to play devil's
advocate
i'm living that life i'm invested yeah
also from a game design point of view if
you look at a log games there's a reason
that um gamification exists there's a
reason that advertising agencies pay
game designers phenomenal amounts of
money a certain amount of what game
designers are meant to be doing is
manipulating you into staring at the
screen for hours for sure totally and
manipulation's a word that i know
frustrates people because it's it's it's
got negative connotations but like
i actually think that's the whole job it
is kind of to make sure you play the
whole way through right and that's i
know game designers will use that phrase
very cautiously because non-game
designers tend to get freaked out by it
but think about like we are making you
stare at a glowing rectangle in the
corner of your room for 50 hours like
that's there's there's some stuff going
on there i can remove the negative
connotation from that
but i can i can there is some
responsibility there responsibility
that's what i'm saying if you're if i'm
if i'm going there's a trust between me
and this is where i think the consent
thing maybe does have some legs is i am
i am you know taking you by the hand and
entertaining you through something and
asking for your investment and actively
playing with your brain a little bit to
make you enjoy it and to stick with it
yeah you are having an emotional reason
but i trust that i i do have very few
situations this is this is a marketing
conversation which which we go back and
forth about because there's this dance
that they have to do between
i i will
go headlong into the wind with this last
of us part two
there was a specific one that's a good
example of our tour right there was a
specific marketing beat that they wanted
to hit
in order to because from the very
conception they knew what they wanted to
do and if they tipped the hand at all
the entire experience could be quote
spoiled so they're like we need to make
sure that people we haven't showed
anything at joel we need to show
something of joel so they did this
trailer and it's one of the last things
that we shot it was it was a decision
that they they
deliberated on laboriously and ardently
um
people got so mad it was like okay well
you are only mad about that i think
because of what you found out which you
were not supposed to find out which blew
our entire marketing campaign
i can understand somebody
taking away the the all of the polemic
and and and the the
the ire that was you know kicked up
just looking at someone from like okay i
got 60 bucks
i'm over my lawns i i
did what i had to do to make this 60
bucks my birthday present christmas
present whatever
i'm going to discuss it has like the
voice of a title
i got 60 bucks i got 60 dollars for my
grandma before she died
[Laughter]
you know i'm 16 years old
[Laughter]
i i feel like they grow up fast yeah
yeah
i let me finish this cigarette right
quick
[Laughter]
listen to me alright
[Music]
i'm like closing my eyes and picturing a
16 year old and i'm a very big fan of it
it's very good
be i guess sixty dollars and i'm gonna
spin on this [ __ ] game
snorting sweat again
oh put the [ __ ] [ __ ] thing in the
disc right the disc you put it in the
[ __ ] thing and you put it in there
and it brings up the wrong is joey okay
but what has he been through
[Laughter]
preschool was a [ __ ] nightmare you
don't need to understand what i had to
deal with
i got my tricycle everywhere with the
preschool right and then like bobby got
paducah you know bobby gabba dude you're
the big guy he should have gone after
three years but he didn't he talks to me
he's like give me your tricycle i'm like
give me your lunch money i haven't got
no lunch money give me a [ __ ] twice
because i swear i gotta break your neck
and i had to stab him i woke up there
small and then got myself again so
anyway i'm sorry i don't encourage you
what was the story oh yeah what was the
point
the kids the kids got sixty dollars
thank you and i'm a spry young lad yeah
i have 60 bucks and i said and then and
then the game does that to me
i can understand someone going
and not liking that being in conflict
with that thinking that there's one
expectation and then there's going to be
another i get that that sucks in the
same way of someone going i've got five
dollars i'm gonna go to the movie
theater i'm gonna go watch bambi
because it's a beautiful story about a
mother and her baby
we've done this the entire time we're
like well i can't believe they did that
it's like watch the rest of the [ __ ]
movie it's a beautiful story
so i i think that there is some
responsibility and we go back and forth
about this all the time i think there's
responsibility to the creatives to
understand how they are marketing their
game
and the the level of expectation that
they are trying to
uh
put out there so people understand the
game that they're making
and then there's also responsibility to
the consumer buyer beware nobody know
what you're getting into but the two of
those are just in conflict with each
other because these people are like we
demand compelling stories that surprise
us we're like okay but we don't want to
bait and switch you is like yeah cause
we'll kill you it's just getting's tough
because you don't it's hard you know i'm
i i did not see any of the
uh lost kill is
i mean the reality though troy is the
audience that are sending those messages
well they will do that yeah and that is
happening
yeah but i didn't see anything
reasonable for you to mention now if
it's not reasonable yes it's not
reasonable to say it sorry i didn't see
any of the leaks that lost this box
i avoided them
and
i'm glad that i didn't see them because
i feel like that was a more emotionally
impactful experience for me by not
having seen that and i am glad it was
not in any of the marketing any of the
things that happened
um
but i also feel like you know thank god
i don't work in marketing because how do
you make those calls it's happening with
uh masters of the universe right now
that show was marketed in all the
trailers at least initially a very
he-man heavy he-man is not really in the
show
and
people are very upset because the
marketing led them to believe it was
another he-man show even though this one
is not called he-man and the master of
the universe has just mastered the
universe but it's mostly a show about
tila so far there are two parts to the
season but people are upset about that
because they felt the marketing was
misleading but
you know marvel uh disney reshoot
trailers occasionally to make sure that
they're not spoiling things for you so
it's a lot more complicated than i think
people think it is to make sure you're
like
we want to have
you we want you to have the best
experience when you play this and we've
decided that if you know this your
experience when you play it will be a
lot weaker so how do you then
say well you were led to think this
wouldn't be here did we mislead you
i don't know how you approach any of
that but then there's also the whole
thing maybe we shouldn't commercialize
art i think maybe
some kind of society sometimes society
where uh we seize the means of
production
and we make things without profit motive
and therefore
our art is free at the point of use and
producing gene roddenberry hey you're
sitting there drinking a beer
that's what i'm saying we should you're
saying they're drinking a pepsi
[Laughter]
buddy are you crying right now that's uh
i am in tears
sweet a lot of pepsi it's good i think
that it would be
i don't know man there's there's
something about having um
you're like man i i i put some money
into this
um i'm i'm you know redoing my or not
redoing but i'm building a home gym
right now just because i got tired of
you know people making fun of your cool
razor people making fun of my cool razor
mask you know it hurts me yeah i'm a
human
are you going to wear the razor masks
i'm going to do my vein voice
i i if
the thing is neither could he so he
couldn't do bane either so i i've got
that on tom hardy and i are you know
twins yeah i i got tired of of um
covid and especially when i went to my
gym and i was like you know you know if
you are not wearing a mask we assume
that you're vaccinated i'm like bye i
just don't want to deal with this like
i've made it this long without getting
this this thing i don't need to prove
that i can get it and show how strong my
immune system is like i i'm vaccinated i
i don't have the benefit of having a an
opinion on this i've got a
three-year-old and there's a lot of
disease and sickness we the
our nanny that we have
like when we first brought her on it was
like what's the goal for him every day i
was like dirty and tired dirty and tired
that's that's what i want you don't want
you to take him out i want him to be
dirty and tired
and
he goes out and and he goes out of the
world and he falls down and he tumbles
and he and he gets sick
which has only been sick like three
times in his life but i don't have a
problem i'm not not trying to shrink
wrap the world for my son i need him to
understand
what it feels like to
that's why i'm so glad that he has
two other kids in his life right now
one of who's his same age and one who's
a year younger and one's his dad troy
baker
huh
what's ronan like like people know that
you know
traveler and ronan are basically cousins
and and and they're they're two months
apart and there's another one who's
who's two years old that tries to keep
up with the big kids and my point is
that you're also a kid that was very
quiet
oh i got it yeah it's true playing
[ __ ] video games
i
i want him to understand um
what triggers one person may not trigger
the other person and i do believe that
there is how do we establish that
standard because we should let people
know there's there's some payment i were
talking about this there's some videos i
saw on youtube that i wish that i never
would have seen
and i can't unsee those things and i
actively went and searched for them
um
because i have a
we're all drawn to the macabre for for
one reason or another we want to
experience why we get on roller coasters
we want to feel that rush of death but
know that we're going to be safe so we
can just deal with it and understand is
one of my favorite phrases that i
learned from this book is
death i have visited with you many times
now pass through the gates of my
imagination and let us visit his friends
that to me is the goal for for me on my
deathbed to be like all right man i've
imagined you many times but now pass
through the gates of my imagination let
us create as friends it's a cycle of
life it's gonna happen
i don't i'm gonna be screaming i think
yeah i know we've talked about this
before you're like oh we screaming
but i want i want traveler to understand
that there's there's bad things in the
world and and here's how you deal with
them and they don't define you and i
don't believe that as us as creatives
all of us on this come in this
conversation as creatives
the product doesn't define us but the
process does and that's why mike you you
work to be
you want to make a great game but you
also want to make sure that you're a
great president that you're a great
company leader that you lead a great
team that you don't push your people too
hard that you're managed that becomes
your game and then the game makes a game
and that's that's that's what i want to
be as well it's it's the process not the
product that is the goal
i like that so do i i'm not sure how we
got here but i like that too i feel good
about it yeah we play boyfriends very
well i am going to play boyfriends
i need people to stop sending awful
stuff to the team it's not fair yeah
the team's being the team's listening
and i think tweaking things to try and
accommodate people it's tough because my
i always want to take the stance of it's
very
easy for me to care about people um i
stopped using the words uh the word
insane and i now say wild instead
because
i was like okay that is a legitimate
mental illness someone pointed it out to
me and i was like
super easy for me to just change that
word and just swap it out i try not to
say crazy as well sometimes you know you
have those habits and they they seep
into your language but my stance is
generally always okay if i can be
compassionate to more people then i'm
going to try to do that but there is
also
you can you can also [ __ ] kill
yourself trying to do that like you can
i probably shouldn't even use that
language you can also just like exhaust
yourself
by creating something and trying to do
that as much as you possibly can that i
feel like it can be really dirty and
tired dirty and tired story of life
there's a phrase
there's a phrase that um
a lot of people use and i looked into it
because i didn't really understand what
the etymology of it was but suffer fools
and we look at people oh he doesn't
suffer fools
that's just code for [ __ ] though
kind of i i had mike does not suffer
this is genuinely true mike does not
suffer fools gladly was written on my
school report at the age of five years
old wow
mike does not suffer fools gladly i
remember seeing that when i was like 12
13 and thinking oh wow i was like a
clever kid and now i know that teacher
was taking the piss do you know where
that phrase comes from i
i don't actually know where it comes
from you're gonna love this the
etymology of that phrase i believe comes
from the apostle paul
and he is writing to a church where he
was like here these people come and they
teach you the truth and you reject it
but you will gladly suffer you suffer
fools gladly these people that are that
are lying to you and so the notion of
people that you shouldn't listen to or
people that have a contrary opinion or
whatever that you don't listen to them
that you don't suffer fools is 100
antithetical to what i want to do it's
it's like a boxer saying
i don't get in the ring and fight other
people man that's not what i do it's
like well then you're not a boxer that's
you need to get in you need to spar so
that you learn how to be a better boxer
so
learn how to suffer fools i'm you should
suffer full as many fools as gladly as
you can i i am i'm not maintaining your
mental health i yes while maintaining
your health mental health sure in the
same way that a boxer goes okay i need i
need to take a break yeah get out of the
room boxer takes a break i i i try and
push myself because i know i know my
instinct is to not suffer fools gladly i
know i do i i try and push myself and
the other the other thing is of course
the arrogance of assuming you can define
who is not who is and who is not a fool
hey look at that that's the biggest one
it's a fall to you i think
the the one thing we've touched on in
this conversation that i would like to
push back on is the idea that audiences
now or modern audiences
are just more willing to let us know
what they think um
they are
but my number one favorite thing about
social media because we talk about the
downsides all the time there's a list
it might just be the ones oh no there
are a few but the removal of of the
class system
previously there were all of these
diverse voices that just didn't exist in
any room in video game development these
people who had no voice in any way
whatsoever who could never speak who
could never be heard uh who would never
even have the chance to be
in the same vicinity as someone who
works in the entertainment medium that
they love and now they do
almost equally sure there are still
verification systems and follower
systems that like weed that stuff out
but i think that that is a massive
positive of twitter is that there are
more voices that everyone is able to
hear
sometimes those are negative and
overwhelming but i still think the that
the fact that we've actually found
something to remove real world classism
is pretty fantastic
i is democratization i think it's great
i think there's a level playing field
where it's like hey we can look at this
but in the same way
anyone who is on the dev side can look
at that and go i want you to keep in
mind
this is
it's it's the you know take it with a
grain of salt
but you can look at the fact of like
again with the with the example of last
of us part two there were years of of
game testers
you know the scores of people that sat
down without you know the the marketing
leaks and we're playing through that and
going
if it didn't hit we iterate
is it hitting
let's iterate and finally it was like in
step we're like man this is we're
getting the real-time data that this is
really landing with people they're
playing through it they get it
and it wouldn't it wasn't like they were
like nobody gets it [ __ ] it ship the
game it was like
what do we need to change this mo this
moment isn't hitting how do we help it
hit do we need to rewrite a city that's
i mean that's usually the goal of the
creative right no the creator generally
wants the data that's going to make
their work better and to be clear like i
don't i'm definitely not uh with this
theme on the show for sure but i'm not
i'm not anti-criticism quite the
opposite i think where it's crossed
align with this with this boyfriend
dungeon thing is there is an interesting
conversation to be had and i think it's
the one we've been having about kind of
how how media should warn about content
what the unders what the expectations of
the player are etcetera
the problem here is there's a lot of
abuse being sent to the development
absolutely is it actionable
yeah well well no no your game's [ __ ]
and i don't like it it's absolutely
valid criticism as well i think the
difference here is there's a lot of
people who are sending you death threats
or accusing the developers the actor who
plays the uh
bad character is also being pretty
horrifically
harassed
oh i saw that yeah yeah and this isn't
like a big name this is just a guy that
that got a deal
all right i yeah i suppose he's very
good from what i've seen and i wish
there was something actionable we could
do about stop harassing people um shall
we shall we leave the show there we stop
harassing people stop harassing stop
harassing people and we don't have the
answers to this conundrum but it's a
very interesting conversation and we
would love to hear your criticism of our
conversation in the comments below
oh no
this is play watch listen everybody i'm
alana that's troy oh that's mike and
austin already left bye